atmosphere.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the open opening verses of
chapter number 68.
also known as
oron.
All of them are correct. All of them are
referenced by the scholars of Islam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala begins this
chapter by saying noon
noon.
Now this word
in the Arabic language
we mentioned has three meanings.
Non as a word
the spoken word non has three meanings.
Three potential meanings.
Number one,
who can tell me one of them?
Huh? A whale. the fish, right? Okay.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
okay what is the second
the second meaning of the word noon in
Arabic is a det
What is a det
very close? It could be a bucket, but
it's used mostly
is used mostly to mean an ink. Well,
a bucket is an very close similar
etmology.
A dowet is an inkwell.
You know, an ink will where it's the
little
[Arabic recitation]
traditionally when you would write the
the pens, they didn't automatically
fill. You had to dip in the in the in
the inkwell and then write. Right. So,
is a bucket
is an inkwell.
Wasam.
[Silence]
Huh?
And what is the third meaning of noon?
Right. The letter.
Now here is a very interesting point.
Which one of these is the correct me
meaning
the letter is
very good. Mashallah. The correct
opinion is that noon here is the letter.
Why?
Because it's written in the mus by the
companions as what? As a letter.
Correct? Now that's if you see it
written in the musaf. But if you hear
it, if you hear it,
the Arab who is well-versed in the
Arabic language, which of these meanings
would come to mind? All of them correct.
The letter would come to mind. The whale
would come to mind. The inkwell would
come to mind. You know what's
interesting? All three of these are
mentioned in this surah.
All three of these meanings are
mentioned in this surah. The letter
itself,
every verse ends with what? With noon.
And it is the most frequent letter in
the chapter. So much so that you could
refer to the chapter as noon or noon
because it is the most frequent
letter utilized in this chapter to
comprise this chapter of number two. The
whale Allah says at the end of the
chapter
[Silence]
This meaning at the is mentioned in the
chapter and also the inkwell is
mentioned or alluded to as one of the
three components used to write. In order
for me to write something, I need three
things, right?
I need to have ink. I need to have a
pen. And I need to have something to
write on. Right.
Right. All three of these things are
mentioned here in these opening verses.
However, when we want to say which one
is strongest, the letter non,
right? But the other two come to mind.
And this is what we refer to in English
as a double meaning or a pun or
sometimes it's referred to as a double
antandra. But in in in modern use of the
word double antandra, it usually holds a
negative meaning, right? A vulgar
meaning, a comedic meaning. However, a
pun for instance, let's say does
anybody here know a pun they can share
with us?
Let me get creative. Let's say I was a
boss,
you know, imagine, right? Imagine I'm
a CEO. I'm a big shot. All right?
And
I have some workers and some of them are
overweight, right? and I need to lay
some people off.
Right? So I say we need to trim we need
to trim the fat here in this in this
in this company. No pun intended,
right? So I only fire the fat people and
I say no pun intended. This is what we
call a pun. It could be a metaphorical
or it could be literal. Right? This is
usually how puns work. When we have this
in the Quran, this is extremely common
in the Quran. Extremely common. And it's
one of the reasons why Allah chooses the
words that he does. He could choose a
single word that would not have any
other meaning to it. It could only mean
one thing. But instead, he opts to
choose a a word that has two, three,
four, five meanings. Some of them have
up to 14 meanings. The word
has 14 meanings in the Arabic language.
The word summed has seven meanings in
the Arabic language. The word
has up to 12 different v variant
meanings in the Quran alone. Now are all
these intended all of the time? No.
However, very often
when a word is used, another more
specific word could have been used, but
Allah opts for the and chooses the more
general. That's on purpose. That's by
design. That's for these things to come
to mind. So when you hear
we know this is the letter, this is the
whale and this is what the ink
the ink will right three things the
letter is what's intended not just
because of as Abu is Abu Hazim right Abu
Hazim as Abu Hazim told us because of
how it's written written, but also how
it's recited.
What do you mean how it's recited? When
we go to recite,
when a silent noon
meets a well
in the science of
what happens to the noon
The noon when it is second and it meets
a wow.
The
tongue does not make contact with its
final place but there is what is
called which means we skip straight to
the well. So it would be recited,
right? But that's not how it's recited
in the major recitations.
[Silence]
This only happens if the noon and the
wow this this only happens if it is a
separate word. And if we were to do that
issue of we it would change the
meaning. The intended meaning is the
letter. We know this by the way it's
written and we know this by the way that
it is recited. However, the other two
meanings do come to mind and the other
two meanings are mentioned in the same
chapter.
He says noon, meaning the letteron,
and I swear by the pen and what they
write.
I swear by the pen and what they write.
Here we have a mention of the pen. Allah
swears by it. He says,
forctoch.
[Silence]
for
Bean.
[Silence]
And so this word here, I swear by the
pen. Is it the pen with a capital T or
is it the pen meaning the the the
instrument that is the pen? If we were
to say the pen with a capital T, this
would be a reference to which pen?
Which pen?
Huh? The first creation. The pen that
Allah first created when he created the
heavens and the earth. What did our
prophet say? He said that the first
thing Allah created was the pen and he
said to it write said what shall I
write? He said write what is to be until
the day of judgment. That pen that is if
we understand it to be the T with a
capital T the pen. What about if we
understand it to be the pen meaning the
general pen the instrument. we
would say the pen is mightier than the
sword. Which pen? The instrument that is
the pen and what it does right this
would mean all pens any pens. The art of
writing because writing is like
telepathy isn't it? Why do we say the
the pen is mightier than the sword? That
is very correct. The scholars they have
a saying. They say
They say nothing matches or supersedes
the blood of a martyr except for the ink
of a scholar. Why?
You know this issue of a pen being able
to communicate ideas
by way of writing.
This here
is
telepathy.
Imagine I can write this this book in my
hand right now.
This is a of the Quran. It was written
by
and before that the other half the
second half is written by
hence the the word.
These men passed away more than 500
years ago,
almost 600.
Now I'm reading. They're communicating
their words to me
across centuries
and across countless miles. How did
their words reach me here and get into
my mind and in my heart? And I am saying
their words. They're using my tongue to
say their words.
Is that not a superpower? Tell me that's
not a superpower.
That is telepathy. You know how the
human being always fantasizes about a a
telepath, someone who can, you know,
crawl into someone else's mind and make
them say things and make them do things.
This is telepathy.
We take it for granted because in our
time it's so ubiquitous. It's so common
place. Everyone is literate. This is
telepathy.
And this is why literacy is so important
in our time. Do you know why it's so
important in our time? Why does the
government care so much that you and you
and you and him and her, they all know
how to read? Why is that so important?
Tell me.
Why do they care? Influence. Why was the
printing press designed originally?
Originally, was it because the wealthy
and intellectuals wanted to share this
this knowledge with the impoverished? Is
that why they looked at the common slave
and the common man and they said, "If
only you knew what I knew." I need to
design something so that I can
communicate this knowledge to all the
world because I want everyone to know
what I know. Is that why? Huh? Why the
reason the printing press was invented
in the first place was in order to make
propaganda
individualized
right control.
We say the pen is mightier than the
sword. It is because I cannot make
someone believe something with a sword
but with a pen I can.
I can I can make men draw their swords
or sheathe them with the pen. With the
pen, I can communicate with men and
women in the future. I can change the
future with my pen today sitting at a
desk. Isn't that amazing?
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"I swear by the pen."
This means anytime Allah swears by
something in the Quran, I swear by this.
I swear I swear by the moon. I swear by
the sun. This is not for us to just
overlook.
You need to take a hard stop
and really sit and think about what
Allah is saying because when I in
language when we swear by something
let's say I want you to believe
something I'm saying and I swear I say
to you I swear by Allah what am I
essentially saying by that
what am I essentially saying
well I'm saying believe me but what What
does that mean about what I'm saying
about Allah?
[Arabic recitation]
then you know Allah is too great for me
to mention his name and lie in the same
sentence. Right? So in language, I only
swear by something that I find to be
what? great, significant, exalted,
above, being used
in that which is lowly. I wouldn't swear
by any little thing. Right? I wouldn't
swear by any little thing. I only swear
on big things, on major things, on huge
things, things that are grave, things
that are grand.
Right? So whether it is the thing that
I'm swearing by or the reason I'm
swearing, it is only for the most
important things that I would take an
oath. Now for Allah, he swears by whom
he chooses, what he chooses, when he
chooses. It is his creation and it is to
his discretion.
But as for the human being, can we swear
by anything or anyone?
We can only swear by Allah. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam says
[Silence]
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said whoever of you is to swear then he
is to swear by Allah or remains silent.
And he further said whoever swears by
other than Allah has fallen into a type
of kufur or shik. And he further said he
is not of us the one who swears by am
right. You know we this is a thing that
the Arabs especially they find the
entrustment to be a major thing right.
So so they say they will swear by am we
have this even in our modern times.
And so the point is is that
when Allah swears by something he is
doing that in order to take the level
take the words that are being said to
the highest of levels of believability.
But on top of that he is articulating
the grandiosity of the thing that he is
swearing by. Now look at the pen. Allah
said at the very beginning all the way
back four chapters ago,
he said describing himself
described himself as the one who taught
by way of the pen. He taught the human
being what he did not know before. He
taught by way of the pen in order for me
to have an advancement in knowledge. I
can't go back to zero every generation.
We'll never get anywhere. Correct?
I take what is learned and known from
the past and then I embody it. I embibe
it, right? Absorb it, understand it, and
then I build on top of it. Then I
document it and pass it on to the next
generation and the next generation and
the next generation until we have
advancements.
Right? And this is why we can see
humanity went from what they refer to as
the stone age to the bronze age to the
iron age. Right? Why? Because we were
able to refine our knowledge. Without
the pen, would this be possible? It
would not be possible. it would not be
possible.
The pen is so mighty and it is so
dangerous.
It is so dangerous
and that is why it is imperative
that whenever we commit something to
writing or whenever we subject ourselves
to reading we only choose the best. The
prophet sallall.aii
used to make dua.
Allah, I seek refuge in you from
knowledge that is of no consequence.
If he's seeking refuge from knowledge
that is of no consequence,
what could be said for knowledge that is
destructive?
You know how many people died or were
murdered in the 20th century between
World War I and World War II? You know
how many? More than 80 million.
It said that 10,000 people would die a
minute in World War I. How much blood?
You know where that came from?
Darwin sitting in his table writing the
ideas
that the human being was a fish that
crawled out of the ocean and grew
lengths. That's where it came from.
Communism, socialism, capitalism, ,
Nazism, fascism, in their most bloody
forms all root back to the same common
ancestor, Darwin.
Charles Darwin.
That's an idea. He had an idea.
He had an idea and he wrote a book
called the origin of the species. And he
said in the origin of the species that
he could imagine the reverse to be true
in the first edition. He could imagine
the reverse to be true. What is the
reverse? That you know we all share a
common ancestor. We came out of the
water and were apes and then we became
humans. The opposite could be true. He
could imagine a bear. Listen to
insanity. What it sounds like. He could
imagine a bear that goes down to the
water every day, goes down to the to
fish at the ocean every day. That if he
and his children and his children's
children and children's children's
children continued to do that for
thousands or millions of years, that
that bear would eventually turn back
into a whale.
Wow, that's amazing. Could you imagine
what would I need to live underwater?
What would have to change of my bi
of my biology to live underwater? That's
saying you could imagine a Honda
Civic turning into a submarine
eventually, right? It's insanity. But
because of how it was written and
because of the propaganda, what did it
turn into? It turned into the basis of
fascism, communism, Marxism, socialism,
and plays a huge part in capitalism.
All of this came from this one man.
That's how powerful ideas are. Look at
us here right now. We're all talking and
spending our time with this. What what
are we spending our time doing? We are
reading and contemplating the book of
Allah, the Quran, and what has caused it
to reach us in no small part, the pen.
We take it for granted, but it is one of
the mightiest instruments Allah has ever
bestowed upon any creature.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. We will take a stop
there. We'll continue this tomorrow,
[Arabic recitation]